free bounty george keeps his head eye as  he moves it left to right george cross  over drive middle to the lane towards  all the way inside  he slams with two kevin and a foul  might as well call this man the  notorious tt  he can beat back the defense  and his hair is nicer look at  he does not have a salmon suit  no only one of us along the broadcast  row has a salmon  don't let the smooth taste fool you now  don't let it  don't let it fool you all right one half  of play complete  the clippers have picked up where they  left off from the previous game in game  three  this team looked unstoppable in the  first half that was the perfect half of  basketball you know  no rush here for la leonard seven to  shoot kawhi makes his move oh  wow a major kawhi light  oh my goodness put a frame on that  poster  on three goes down for joe ingles  my goodness  that was intense i mean the cutouts  started to jump up and applauded